she's more likely to she's more likely
to cheat as well no no no no no no she's
no she no she's no she no no okay we
talked about this
if she slept with more people she's not
she's more likely to cheat and if a guy
slept with more people it's not the same
okay um
if uh because it's the thing is a dude
can be broke short and riding through as
well
right men and women are the same
either way how can a man be random but
this is the thing guys if you look at
the other side of it yeah
a man
is
a woman when they have sex right a man
is coming inside of you yeah like you
end up holding on to that like sperm
doesn't just leave your body so i get
there's a certain level in terms of like
how many partners you should be with and
how accessible you are to a man and just
anyone and everyone but
i get the sense of like i wouldn't if i
was a man i wouldn't want a woman that's
just been with everyone i wouldn't want
as a woman i don't want a man that's
been with exactly and and
why do you say that a hoe deserves to be
courted like why should another dude put
up with that because if even if she she
may have had sex with other people one
to be honest let's be very very honest a
hoe is probably gonna make you come
faster than a virgin
so she probably will wha what you want
from her she can probably give it to you
better than a virgin can a hoe will
probably still be able to cook still be
able to clean still be able to educate
your kids if you're broke and you're
short you won't be able to provide and
you're not going to perform
one the one thing that you're missing is
that men value loyalty and the point
that pearl's trying to make is that she
might be able to clean like you said she
might be able to cook she might she
might exhibit all of these traits right
however and she might she might give you
good sex but men value loyalty and given
her sexual status she's far less likely
to be loyal that's what men are aiming
for it's the thing is right
like that is still uh
that's still like a a maybe she might be
less loyal it's also equally happy
so you said okay you said you said you
saw my tick tock right
oh yeah i said like you said you were
you were before the show you said you
were triggered by my tick tock truth
you're not triggered you were upside
down you were you felt something
i felt that you have a platform and you
sometimes you're irresponsible with the
things that you say
do you know which thing upset me the the
five body count one no no no
when a girl said that she spent her 20s
finding herself and you said what does
that mean you don't spend but so many
women have to take time finding
themselves you were raised in a really
beautiful home with a beautiful family
with five older brothers that looked
after you not everybody i've ever
brought them i don't know
but but you had to basically draw on
your own you had siblings that helped
you build character and helped you feel
comfortable with who you are not
everybody has that same footage i
understand that but the point is the
world doesn't owe you understanding so
yeah no but you are when you're saying
that like you deserve to be courted by
someone like the key word is deserve
nobody deserves anything and i can ask
you a question can i ask questions sorry
paul go ahead um so imagine you've got
two guys right you've got one guy
average high average looks average
income right they've got the second guy
right tall good looking confident
intelligent
clearly there's one guy you would you
want more and there's one guy who's seen
as more valuable to you because of what
you look for than the other right so
would you be expected right because it's
gonna be harder to get him
yeah right would you be expected to the
same degree
the same level of effort that you put in
to get his attention to connect with him
right would you expect to have the same
level of effort for the guy that you
find less valuable you're going to have
to redirect the question because i don't
chase
yeah but it's not about chasing but
you're making effort
you don't put effort in with guys at all
can i just ask what's your relationship
have you have you read blind man love
[ __ ]
no are you ready i would say if you had
a boyfriend you would have said that
who aren't you
what was
so basically if i just put in a mutual
amount of effort so if that so that
intelligent whatever guy that's there he
can be there and they can be the average
guy if the average guy is building more
of a relationship with me or making more
effort with me that's who so you don't
you don't reciprocate in dating no i
only reciprocate i don't i'm not going
to
so how are you supposed to let him know
you're interested you don't instigate
basically yeah exactly i don't instigate
it i don't need to choose because that's
what he's saying if you had two men in
front of you how would you like how are
you going to choose you're automatically
going to change i'm not going to want a
guy that wants me to chase him okay so
it's not about chase and that's my point
if you have two opportunities like both
of them don't know about each other and
you're speaking to them both you're
automatically going to choose the one
that is more suited to you
like you're not going to choose the one
just because of well unless you care
more about personality depending on what
your values are i do care more about
personality but that's what i'm saying
so how do you choose and he's saying
like how would you do that so if you're
the last woman on earth you decide you
decipher the value but let me quickly
ask you a question so
just just a little
look into a man's brain right regardless
what any man wants to say
men off the bat we want to have sex
right so you said previously that every
single woman should be caught with the
same okay everyone should be caught with
the same so if a man was to call a woman
say over three months hypothetically
right the males caught a woman over
three months
he spent his time money resources
all of his energy on you do you believe
once he's done that
you owe him sex no i don't believe i owe
him anything but if i want to have sex
with him i'll have sex with him
but he has to do
all this stuff for you that's the
biggest idea you're not doing anything
for him i didn't say i'm not going to do
anything for him
i said i said that women deserve to be
courted so i think that all women
deserve especially and i think as well
it's the intention that you have for the
woman so if you're dating women to find
your like life partner
then yeah then definitely you should
take time to court them properly if
you're dating women to [ __ ] then call
date women to [ __ ]
even quiet so even the women that say oh
men are trash men are xyz men don't
deserve this from me men don't need this
from me i'm a like uh kevin samuel says
i'm a independent woman i can do things
on my own like
why why do they need to be courted if
they can do it on their own they can
take their selves out to them they can
take their self they can court
themselves
essentially why do they why do they
deserve to be courted if they're not
essentially going to
give reciprocate the
reciprocated for the man so the thing is
for me right i feel that relationships
and you're probably all gonna attack me
for this but it's what i feel and what i
believe i feel relationships marriage
is more advantageous for men than it is
for women i feel that men need women
more than women need men
and
because of that
men should make more effort
and like
yeah even if those women that feel that
men are trash men are this or
all of those types of women they can
either choose to be single and they'll
be happy or if a man wants them that man
should work to prove them wrong and work
to have them on their side awesome okay
so okay so
how do women how do men you said women
or men need women more than women need
men yeah how is that true when they want
everything that in society what do you
mean everything the power supply the
emphasis the entire infrastructure of
society oh it's it's very simple it's
because construction needs sex more than
women need sex but can i just quickly
say that's all you offer
oh who offers that's all you offer
that's
that's not all you offer generally
speaking the things that you believe you
offer a man we point blank don't give a
[ __ ] about yeah you can offer
personality you can offer the ability to
clean the house unless you're loyal and
the pussy's good we genuinely don't give
a [ __ ] more than any so basically i know
all men really care about is sex
basically
yeah all men care about is sex and every
woman has the ability to give a man sex
basically and so what do women need from
men
okay
sustainability suitability wait wait
pause protection from what if someone
breaks into your house who who who
protects you the people police
[Music]
do men not run the police department the
fire department all those no no those
are those are men in society i'm talking
about men in your relationship
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible